allora buongiorno a tutti grazie per
l'ospitalità io dirigo questa rete che
una rete un'associazione nazionale non
ha una sua specifica un profilo sulla
sull'emigrazione si occupa di modalità
di socialità cultura popolare o un
termine assolutamente ambiguo perché
quando si passa alla cultura popolare si
pensa a folklore alle feste al carnevale
in realtà tutto quello che significa
cultura popolare significa studiare i
modelli di socialità che ci sono
all'interno delle comunità
lecce occupiamo essendo la maggior parte
di noi provenendo dal mondo
antropologico sociologico di studiare
quelle che erano le modalità di
socializzazione precedenti alla società
di consumi quindi quella che ha a che
fare con la società rurale dalla quale
se non i nostri padri
almeno i nostri nonni derivavano quanto
di quella realtà si è trasferita nel
contemporaneo
e così ci occupiamo di cose molto
contemporanea dal microcredito di
comunità a un all'abitazione condivisa
al lavoro e alla ricerca di come quel
lavoro deve essere trasferita e
riqualificare per esempio un certo tipo
di lavoro che fino a poco tempo fa era
destinato oggi da tempo fa neanche molto
tempo fa quando ero più giovane io se tu
non riusciva ad arrivare a un livello di
scolarizzazione abbastanza alto
era un fallimento c'è sempre più la
convinzione almeno nei nostri giri
quello che stiamo vedendo con
confartigianato c'è una richiesta invece
di lavoro altissima per persone che
hanno altre capacità che non sono quelli
dell'inter detto ma quelle manuali che
sappiano fare qualche cosa e quindi si
sta lavorando a progetti vari non ve la
dico tutta di rimando al sito della rete
vv rete italiana cultura popolare punto
org dove potrete vedere moltissimi di
questi
e una rete disseminata su tutto il
territorio nazionale
oggi stiamo parlando di 8.000 persone
iscritte alla rete circa 40 province 10
regioni oltre 350 comuni che hanno
aderito e parte dal basso anche tutte
iniziative ogni volta si costruisce una
sede nei vari territori e si vedono i
bisogni delle necessità vendite dei
posti dei territori
la sede operativa nazionale a torino ed
è da lì che siamo partiti con quella che
l'idea di oggi per la quale sono stato
chiamato cioè quella di indovina chi
viene a cena b spiegherei prima del dl
come avviene della sua origine perché
così capiamo anche perché una rete come
questa aveva necessità di incontrarsi
noi abbiamo sviluppato da poco
lo presenteremo con il professor tullio
de mauro adesso a fine marzo un archivio
partecipato sulla cultura popolare
ovvero non esiste in italia un
calendario di riti feste tradizioni
condiviso
cioè non esiste ogni comune c'è il suo
c'è la regione molise che ha fatto un
lavoro interessante ma verso l'italia
non ce lo abbiamo deciso di partire
sono sette università messa in rete con
il miur abbiamo stiamo sviluppando una
piccola applicazione per la quale i
ragazzi potranno andare direttamente
anche quelli delle scuole a fotografare
video riprendere intervistare andranno
direttamente in questo archivio c'è un
comitato scientifico naturalmente dietro
questa in tutto questo abbiamo iniziato
a tirar giù quello che il calendario ci
siamo accorti terribilmente che il
calendario è variato perché alle nostre
feste dalle madonne e santi e tutti gli
affreschi che volete si sono aggiunti i
capodanni cinesi o 17 le pasque
ortodosse cioè si sono aggiunte di
ramadan si sono aggiunte moltissime
altre altre feste che non sono più
sporadiche e non muovono nicchie
ma muovono una quantità di persone non
indifferente e hanno un'influenza sulla
modalità di socializzazione hanno
un'influenza sull'economia e hanno
un'influenza sulla capacità di incontro
nelle città fuori dentro i grandi centri
urbani enorme allora una domanda era
allora questo calendario ma rivisto va
rivisto va rivisto con le persone che
aderiscono a quelle feste
come facciamo nei piccoli paesi così
dobbiamo fare
ecco il nostro incontro con le culture
altre di tradizione diversa ecco perché
la rete italiana si è occupato di ciò
semplicemente per cui non per una sua
vocazione all'intercultura ma perché ci
si confronta nel quotidiano
questo è l'unico modo per noi di fare le
cose quello che abbiamo fatto
così ci siamo entrati in contatto con
alcune associazioni l'associazione
soprattutto della romania perché in
piemonte la popolazione
credo siano 55 mila persone a torino ma
tantissimi procede la seconda strada c'è
la marocchina la terza dal bar in
accelerazione
le associazioni intorno a queste unità
sono diventate molte l'associazione
rumena solo a torino a una decina di
associazioni così però come capita come
capitava per gli italiani che andavano
soprattutto negli stati uniti ogni
associazione spesso non dialogava ovvero
adesso ci sono i numeri erano tante
isole non c'era un film fra loro
anzi spesso non in contrasto uno contro
l'altro le stesse cose capitavano agli
italiani negli stati uniti il feeling
anzi non esistevano
durante un festival che organizziamo a
torino tutti gli anni che si chiama
festival internazionale dell'oralità
popolare ovvero di tutto quello che
viene trasmesso attraverso il sapere del
corpo della voce e non attraverso lo
scritto qui del lavoro della gastronomia
etc
abbiamo invitato alcune associazioni chi
ha risposto erano quelle un po più
capaci cioè avevano dei leader capaci di
interagire con gli italiani ci siamo
accorti di aver fatto fuori tantissime
altre persone cioè non si sa non ha non
entravamo in contatto con la comunità
entrava in contatto con una di queste
associazioni era entrare in contatto col
mondo di quell'associazione che spesso
era il leader
dieci persone intorno era un consiglio
direttivo una cosa di questo genere e
quelle 50 persone che seguivano quella
associazione ii e presentava un libro il
cerchio nato era cambiato completamente
tutto così abbiamo iniziato a chiamare
tutte le associazioni un dialogo che è
durato tre anni non facile e poi man
mano conquistando una reciproca fiducia
abbiamo iniziato a portare in piazza il
loro cibo non in quanto gastronomia ma
in quanto espressione di una ritualità
ovvero loro portavano cibi dedicate ai
matrimoni
ai funerali alle loro feste che si
confrontavano con i nostri
la fiducia è cresciuto talmente tanto e
l'amicizia è preso talmente tanto che
gli abbiamo proposto un progetto che
doveva essere un progetto di
condivisione quindi indovina chi viene a
cena è un posto dove sicuramente si
mangia si mangia bene si sta insieme ma
in realtà è un progetto di incontro puro
vuol dire che tu accetti l'idea di
incontrare un'alterità tant'è che
abbiamo costruito un vademecum
attualmente viene fatto in circa dieci
comuni italiani da lecce a roma
hanno prato grosseto torino muove una
cosa come più di 150 famiglie e che
quindi ospitano ogni fine l'ultimo
sabato del mese circa 400 persone in
tutta italia crea una sorta di
microeconomia di solidarietà perché
chiunque va a casa di una di queste
famiglie
lascio naturalmente un popolo come se
venisse tutti a casa mia a mangiare
carne vi chiederei a ognuno di voi con
partecipare alla carne costa
allora abbiamo deciso che ognuno abbiamo
fissato un vademecum perché chiunque si
scrivesse la rete in questo contesto
sapesse le regole consigliamo non meno
di 15 euro per sicuro che mangereste per
30 euro insomma l'ospitalità e è
fantastica se volete conoscere cosa è
successo come come cosa accaduto in
argentina
potete leggere tutti i giornali che
volete mandate dalla signora argentina
che il marito che avevano una macelleria
e che il giorno dopo la serranda era
chiusa forse è un altro l'impatto con la
storia
una storia immediata così come se volete
conoscere quante divergenze
assomigliante può avere l'islam con con
con la nostra cultura
andate a casa loro allora su questo
siamo trovati molte difficoltà
il primo giorno abbiamo testato noi
della rete siamo andati a casa e prova a
mangiare e poi dire beh ti lascio i
soldi dopo che visto le foto dei figli
di matrimoni
cioè se è entrata in contatto colore è
impossibile che non è così
il vademecum si è reso necessario
tant'è che una delle notizie che diamo e
fa metti soldini una busta chiusa
entra saluta mentre sul comodino e tela
dimentica perché così abbiamo creato un
rapporto dove poi veramente siamo amici
allora in quel contesto si si è tentato
questo meccanismo abbiamo sperimentato
per mesi a torino provando tutte le le
possibilità abbiamo tutte le volte sul
sito troverete le persone che commentano
anche criticamente quella cosa non è
andata quella cosa sia eccetera eccetera
e man mano e questo questo modello
ognuno se la adattata a modo suo a casa
sua e ha funzionato e sta funzionando
sta funzionando sta uscendo anche sui
giornali impensabili quando è arrivato
su vanity fair noi ci siamo anche di
bari
ci sembra una cosa straordinariamente
non mai comprato in vanity fair in vita
mia e ho dovuto comprare per leggere che
cosa diceva naturalmente sbagliano quasi
tutte le cose perché lo prendevano come
ormai essendoci la grande politica di
slow food
andate a mangiare etnico a un certo
punto ci chiamavano ci volevamo andare
cinese e noi gli davamo tutti i
ristoranti cinesi di torino
di prato c'è il tool tra l'altro non non
puoi scegliere in uno di questi
vademecum tu scegli di aderire noi il
giorno prima che diciamo dove andare no
cognome numero telefonico tu accetti di
andare lì basta incontrare qualcuno non
puoi scegliere di andare a mangiare
perché altrimenti va in un ristorante
indovina chi viene a cena e è tutto
questo ma è anche la capacità di potersi
incontrare con altri italiani che tu non
conosci in una casa marocchina invece
che vanga delle sci invece dal congo le
comunità che hanno aderito sono
tantissime e abbiamo contattate
attualmente per quanto riguarda tutta
italia ci sono 25 paesi di provenienza
c'è la possibilità di mangiare chi
gestisce questi sono dei volontari e
naturalmente prendono il nome cognome
delle persone anche numero di scarpe
delle persone perché ricordiamoci che
l'atto di coraggio lo fa chi apre la
porta non chi va a casa milà privata qui
sei tu che vieni da me ora avere un
italiano in casa è sempre pericolosi
esportiamo la più grande azienda
multinazionale di mafia camorra eccetera
eccetera e non si sa mai chi ti circonda
ai tutti i riferimenti dal numero delle
scarpe al colore degli occhi eccetera
dopodiché poi mandarli a casa
di queste brave persone che più
ospiteranno capita come capitato a me
che pasquetta io l'ho fatta con me le
due mie bambine e due signori una cinese
l'altro
marocchino che non hanno però era la mia
festa e quindi loro hanno accettato di
venire con me in un parco pubblico della
città a mangiare ci siamo ci siamo
divertiti cosa succede succede che per
me è un'esperienza nuova
io sono un emigrante gli origo da napoli
arriva a torino
mio padre arrivò grazie a papà o mamma
fiat dormì per un mese alla stazione
ferroviaria di porta nuova
perché c'erano i cartelli non si affitta
ai meridionali poi trovò una soffitta
insieme altri 8 che arrivavano da napoli
e dormi per sei mesi in questa soffitta
poi arrivano i primi soldini si sono
sono diventati da 84 succede in questi
ultimi 20 anni
alcune parole che sembrano non avere
intaccato in realtà ci hanno fatto
malissimo e mio padre a un certo punto
quando lui e faceva l'operaio per certo
punto iniziato avere un po difficoltà
perché fatto troppi figli siamo in
quattro e quindi ha dovuto ricominciare
a studiare poi gli ultimi dieci anni era
un infermiere
ultimamente anche gli infermieri hanno
c'era una grande richiesta allora hanno
problemi a trovare il lavoro e ho
sentito dire da mio padre è perché ci
sono tutti questi extracomunitari che ci
rubano investire capite è una mazzata
pensare che lui possa dire una cosa di
questo genere succede che un giorno deve
dipingere casa nel dipingere casa chiama
l'imbianchino costa circa 1.200 euro
io dico guarda che un amico viene dalla
romania è una persona affidabile
eccetera
lui molto timoroso poi capisce che
questo ragazzo prende 600 euro per fare
questo lavoro è evidentemente motivi
economici vincono sempre e quindi
accetta di far entrare joseph in casa
josé fa tutto benissimo lavoro splendido
io adesso non dico tutte le domeniche ma
una domenica sì e una domenica no joseph
e a casa mia con mio padre a vedere il
napoli quando la prima volta che l'ho
beccato avanti alla televisione del
napoli ha detto papà ma tu mi aveva
detto che lui era rumeno quindi ma tre
centri rumeni sono come noi il senso di
questo è che l'ha incontrato
semplicemente che l'abbia incontrata al
tavola che l'hanno votato su una scala a
fare lo ha incontrato quindi indovina
chi viene a cena non è un progetto su
trovare il cibo degli altri ma è un
progetto che ti porta a incontrare
l'altro questo deve avere come
fondamento che poi si mangia benissimo
si lo so io le sto facendo quasi tutti
che poi si mangia bene che poi si crea
delle amicizie che poi si va avanti
questo è un senso io volevo però
leggervi una delle quattro minuti su
questa cosa veramente per una
un'accertata non credo venga da roma una
delle persone che si è iscritta aderito
chi ha scritto scherzando e giocando con
il bimbo hunan
ho sentito che la dicotomia italiano
immigrato non esiste né per lui né per
me è un'aberrazione della relazione tra
di il nostro paese per entrambi in
italia nella stessa misura in cui il suo
piatto preferito tipico italiano sono le
patatine fritte ed è il suo piatto
preferito tipico dei banca delle
sono le patatine fritte inutile negare
che anche per me così solo che a
differenza di hunan
non oso dirlo interessante è stato
incontrare gli altri partecipanti chissà
come sarebbe diversa una nostra
discussione insieme sull'argomento
immigrazione dopo aver condiviso questa
esperienza ottimi piatti prelibati che
la signora preparato per noi
laddove i limiti linguistici che
ostacolavano il tempo che ci ha dedicato
cucinando
non oso immaginare quanto e la sua
bravura nella preparazione delle
pietanze ci hanno senz'altro fatto
andare oltre una cosa mi dispiace averli
tempestati di domande non è attraverso
questo che si arriva alla conoscenza
spero mi perdoneranno ma forse era
necessario almeno per me la prossima
volta non lo sarebbe più da questa
serata ho capito che non siamo noi che
accogliamo gli immigrati in italia sono
loro che raccontandoci della loro realtà
in italia ci restituiscono il nostro
paese in una luce nuova vera lontana
anni luce dai cliché preconcetti e
presupposti è quantomai infondate verità
di cui ci sentiamo possessori solo
perché i media ce le hanno propinato e
noi ce le siamo presi sono loro che
aprendoci gli occhi consentono a noi
italiani con cittadinanza di entrare nè
l'italia vera quella che non vogliamo
vedere perché non ci fa comodo e che non
usiamo conoscere perché alla fine dei
conti siamo proprio noi che l'abbiamo
fatta così quindi li ringrazio
enormemente perché nell'arco di una
serata con la loro splendida ed onesta
ospitalità non solo mi hanno portato a
conoscenza di una realtà nuova
ma hanno cambiato il mio modo schematico
sintetico semplicistico di approccio di
approcciare alle cose
ora ci usiamo vicendevolmente i nomi
propri un'opinione sulla questione
immigrazione non è un'opinione se non è
supportata quantomeno da un tentativo di
conoscenza consiglio quindi tutti di
aderire a queste iniziative e mi auguro
fortemente che possa essere utile ed
interessante a far capire a chi ci
ospita che spesso quello che ci
allontana e ignoranza
non che sia una giustificazione ma
almeno sappiamo cosa potrebbe
avvicinarci no dice ada da roma e ci
arrivano
la maggior parte delle testimonianze
hanno quell'indie quell'indice la
dicendo alla fine si c le due righe era
buono il cibo ci piace funziona ma
quello che è importante è che abbiamo
incontrato quelle persone cosa significa
fare rete che ogni città costruisce
tutto secondo un calendario nazionale e
non avendo noi l'economia per comprare
pagine e pagine sui giornali siamo
riusciti a uscire in tutta italia e
fuori dall'italia grazie al
coordinamento di tanti piccoli perché se
sono 10 15 20 40 comuni che si mettono
insieme fanno quella cosa
tutto diventa più grande diventa un caso
e dal basso si approccia a diventare
qualcosa di più
l'invito naturalmente nel reggio emilia
no credo più vicino a voi cosa avete
avete prato grosseto ma siamo già dal
giu
l'invito è comunque sul sito troverete i
comuni che hanno aderito di andare in
una di quelle case di incontrare
qualcuno di essere voi gli indovina chi
viene a cena o di farvi promotori voi di
indovina chi viene a cena
non c'è bisogno di istituzioni c'è
bisogno di gente che avevo voglia di
farlo e di capire che cosa significa
questo tipo di cultura delle grazie